este año las celebraciones han sido
radicalmente simplificadas para evitar
el riesgo de contagio antes de la
pandemia el papá francisco solía visitar
una cárcel durante la semana santa eso
ha sido cancelado el tradicional rito
del lavamiento de los pies también ha
sido anulado este jueves tanto el
francisco celebró la misa del crisma
dentro de la basílica de san pedro con
una presencia muy reducida de fieles y
concelebrantes del vía crucis que
siempre se organizaba en el coliseo
romano pues este viernes santo se
llevara a cabo en la basílica de san
pedro sin fieles en la plaza de san
pedro de san pedro' sin fieles casi
completamente vacía y el domingo el papa
no se asomará al balcón de la basílica
de san pedro para pronunciar su
tradicional bendición urbi et orbi esta
bendición será transmitida en directo
desde el interior del vaticano
natalia y ante todo esto por supuesto
tengo que preguntarle cómo está el
ambiente dentro del vaticano y también
el ánimo de la gente de los fieles
católicos
pues claramente es un ambiente muy
inusual este año no se ven en los
alrededores del vaticano las hordas de
turistas que siempre llegaban en esta
época del año para asistir a estas
celebraciones la gente aquí te puedo
decir está exhausta está cansada después
de más de un año de restricciones debido
a la pandemia y seguramente este es un
contexto propicio para vivir estos estos
días y que sea una semana santa más
sobria de introspección que en todos los
casos para los creyentes del mundo
entero este es el momento más importante
del calendario litúrgico católico